we had this point we thought if we don't
make the jump now like when what are you
gonna have another opportunity like this
so yeah we decided you know start our
own company I'm Russell I work at
shifted jelly and I'm a co-founder here
but more importantly than that I'm one
of our developers hi I'm Phillip I work
at shifty jelly I'm a co-founder but
also an Android developer we decide we
want to get into mobile apps so we'd see
each other every day at work and then we
kind of go home on the couch you know
sit back and we start coding we do that
for two years but it's been worth it the
fact we can actually go create your own
company off that shit's jelly is an
Adelaide based mobile development
company and we've grown now so we've got
a designer Chris we've got moniker so
who helps us with support we've just
taken another developer so the team's
growing and growing we've always wanted
to create apps that we want to use
ourselves we we really got into podcasts
like in a big way and there's no good
apps for it we thought what's the first
brand-new app we can bring out now that
working full-time and that's where
that's what pocket car started I just
really wanted to sell one bit of
software to someone but now we're number
one in the chart and people actually
using it kind of around the country one
thing that was really exciting that
happened recently is we actually cost 1
million dollars worth of pocket car
sales and that's a really big milestone
you know to put out just one application
on one platform and there's half a
million people using it now we're always
looking for new features to give our
customers they're always saying you know
what's new what's new and with the pace
that Android moves up we're always able
to give them some gear so we've added
the wear support we've added chromecast
support Android auto and one of them was
material design and we think it's repaid
off and made our app much better we
found that when we switch to material
design when we updated our app when we
you know embraced all these new things
that to who was giving us we found
ourselves actually increased by 30% and
the reception we had was amazing you
know people love it you know they they
see this brand new design you know open
up they're familiar with but just a
different take on it we recently
implemented media sessions it allowed
our users to have a consistent back
experience of course all the different
devices and it made our life as
developers much easy
one of the most exciting things we got
to work on was the Android auto platform
so you plug your phone in and bang play
a podcast it's it's just yeah really
cool and there's a really nice forum
around that so you can just jump on the
forum and within five minutes someone's
on there saying you know have you tried
this and we tried that and we found that
really different to like any other
platform seems like in the Android space
you do something good you put it out to
the world and they make it even better
Google always improving their software
their API that really helps us there as
well and it makes our life a lot easier
just this new technology coming out all
the time it's really exciting for me so
can't wait to see what Google is going
to bring out next
you